the binding administration is closing a
trump-era office within the department
of homeland security
set up to assist american citizens who
are victims of crimes allegedly
committed by illegal immigrants
let's bring in former acting attorney
general matt whitaker for reaction to
that and more on the border matt good to
have you back
hello shannon this is the headline from
the associated press it says u.s closes
trump era office for victims of
immigrant crime goes on to say the bind
administration says
it has dismantled a trump-era government
office that was created to help victims
of crimes committed by immigrants
they say that it's going to be something
different now matt there's going to be
an office that's expanded to help
all kinds of people whether they're here
illegally or not
versus just the mission of that
particular office which was to help
americans who said they've been hurt by
illegal immigrants
what do you make of the change
this is a real problem shannon i i see
victims of crimes
as a former prosecutor always needing
more resources not less and this is
going to spread
what limited resources are available to
those victims of crimes
uh to to others that you know that that
maybe are not as
as worthy or not as deserving um you
know especially if we're giving lawyers
to immigrants or
helping other others that are here
illegally so
i think that closing this office sends a
really bad signal
to victims of crimes and to law
enforcement that the biden
administration just doesn't care
as much as the trump administration did
so let's talk about the border because
its situation has only grown
worse and that's by objective data and
numbers coming to us from nonpartisan
government offices
one of the issues i want to talk about
is the drug trafficking issue
roll call had an opinion piece by
senator portman and congressman catco
saying this biden's border policies are
worsening the opioid crisis
traffickers see a green light to move
more fentanyl into the u.s
in the last six months alone border
patrol has seized 5 400
pounds of fentanyl enough to kill 1.2
billion people
or the entire population of the u.s more
than three times
now these lawmakers say the bind
administration's radical policy changes
have encouraged the drug cartels to
smuggle more
unlawful immigrants and lethal illicit
substances across our southern border
what do you make of the situation and
the rise
in things like fentanyl i mean i went
back to check and in 2019 um
u.s sources say 37 000 americans
died by a fentanyl overdose and they
predict the numbers are only going to be
worse
yeah fentanyl is a is a nasty drug
that is really a scourge
in many of our communities and and what
is happening is the more activity and
the more illegal crossings we have
on our border that allows the cartels
to potentially send more drugs and more
illegal items across the border
because there's more people to carry it
and there's more activity and so you
know this this fentanyl is obviously
synthetic opioids generally are killing
americans it's only getting worse the
more that is
is here in the country and being used
and
obviously getting control of the border
is the first step
in trying to arrest this problem of
illegal fentanyl in our communities
and quickly when i get a comment from
you fbi director christopher wray said
yeah there is
cartel activity that is spilling over
into the u.s in a number of things
partially he said
he was answered questioning about people
getting here and then being sort of
indentured servants
to pay back the cartel for getting them
to the u.s he says yeah it's coming
across our border the cartel
control and business yeah chris is
absolutely right i mean these cartels
are taking advantage of a lacks
enforcement structure at the border
right now
and we're seeing ever increasing illegal
activity and that is spilling whether
it's the safe houses
whether it's these illegal car chases at
high speeds
that are injuring and sometimes killing
people and all the other activity you're
seeing around this border that is
is bringing that into the united states
and really moving the border
north uh in a a very concerning way
matt whitaker always great to have you
with us thank you so much
thank you shannon great to see you again
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else